beware
after many millions of years the t-rex
is back
and this giant scary predator is setting
its hungry sights on you
what would running into this dinosaur be
like
how could you possibly escape
and what would happen if it sunk its
teeth into you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were attacked by a t-rex
during the late cretaceous period about
66 million years ago the t-rex was one
of the largest known meat-eating
dinosaurs
its full name tyrannosaurus rex
means king of the tyrant lizards
and it certainly fits the profile
these dinosaurs towered at up to six
meters tall
with the strongest bite of any land
animal that ever lived the t-rex was a
ferocious predator
back in its day it was roaming the once
lush and warm western parts of the
united states
but somehow it's back and it's on the
hunt for you
run
your peaceful walk in the park would
take a turn for the worse
you'd look up and suddenly see the
frightening sight of a t-rex rising
above you
frozen with fear you'd quickly take in
its terrifying features
its powerful tail counterbalancing a
massive skull
its thick neck muscles and its muscular
thighs that would be a good reminder
that you shouldn't have skipped your leg
day at the gym
though i wouldn't advise it you might
involuntarily chuckle at the sight of
the dinosaur's puny two-fingered
forearms
but your amusement wouldn't last long
the t-rex would flash its gigantic teeth
at you
some of those could be 30 centimeters
long
as a fan of the jurassic park film
franchise you might think that the best
thing to do is remain standing as still
as possible
but research suggests that the t-rex had
a sense of vision as good or better than
modern day eagles
yeah now would be a good time to run
another thing jurassic park led you to
believe is that in order to get away
from this predator you'd need to be able
to move as fast as a car
well that would mean running at a speed
of 50 kilometers per hour and that's
impossible for humans
yeah even the world's fastest person
usain bolt with his top speed of 44
kilometers per hour wouldn't make it out
alive
but you'd still have a chance
today scientists debate whether or not
the t-rex could run at all
research supporting the theory that the
dyno could run estimates that this
predator would be able to move at a
moderate pace of about 25 to 40
kilometers per hour
any faster and it would break its legs
on the other hand the t-rex might not
have been able to run at all
instead it would have walked at a slower
than human pace of five kilometers per
hour
that's about as fast as a soft shell
turtle
knowing this you could jog a comfortable
distance from the attacking t-rex
then if you're not a runner soon enough
you'd stop to catch a breath but that
would be a mistake
your moment of relaxation would suddenly
be interrupted by extremely sharp pain
yeah another t-rex has found you with
its amazing sense of smell
and it would sink its teeth into you
with that sharp pain you'd feel your
bones being crushed
the t-rex would be using its so-called
puncture and pull strategy on you
the dinosaur would drag its teeth right
through your flesh and bones
this would be a gruesome way to die
its front teeth would grip and pull you
to shreds while its side teeth tear your
flesh from your body
its back teeth would be moving your body
closer and closer to the t-rex's throat
struggling to break free wouldn't help
you now
your attacker's wide teeth wouldn't
break from your wiggling
after all this dino used to hunt
triceratops and to make things worse the
dinosaur's powerful neck muscles would
thrash you around
these muscles would be strong enough to
throw a 50 kilogram chunk of meat about
5 meters into the air
hey sorry to be so gruesome but what did
you think running into a prehistoric
creature like this would be like
okay maybe you'd have a better chance
against a more modern predator like an
anaconda
but
that's a story
for another
what if